I'm such a fan of all of your films and
I'm particularly interested in asking
about you know a parallel between this
film and well writer which is the
special connection that human beings can
have with animals why does that speak to
you so much it was such an interesting
proposition to tell a war story in this
context I think animals our relationship
with animals kind of expands our
humanity in a strange way I mean even
just if you look at the way we watch
movies sometimes we don't cry when the
people die we always cry when the dog
dies so that this was a very interesting
[Music]
way of applying or an application for a
war story because it had so many
interesting ideas about what is human
and what is animal what is a cage and
what is sanctuary all of those things
were very interesting to discuss within
the cinema of this and my understanding
is that you were not interested in
making a quote war movie unquote that
was not something you wanted to do so
obviously there were aspects of this the
human story and the animal story that
led you to still do it yeah oh yeah of
course um it just seemed like a really
different way and and the other thing
that was so compelling for me was that
it was a woman's experience of war
Antonina virtually never leaves the
grounds so there here's a woman who is
fighting her war with love and
compassion providing sanctuary for such
traumatized people but doing doing it in
a way that kept their dignity and their
humanity with with art and with music
and there
that very sort of feminine experience of
war felt like new territory and and
important to talk about if I understand
correctly the use of animatronic or CGI
non real animals was kept to a bare
minimum how did you determine when you
had to do it that way
we did it that way when we couldn't do
it safely and respectfully with real
animals I couldn't conceive of a way to
make an authentic movie out of a true
this true story about a female zookeeper
and use fake animals I I couldn't I
couldn't do that and we honestly we
didn't have the budget to do that anyway
but you know and I'm going to think
about it working with the animals was
exactly the same way as to work with the
actors which is to create no I don't
mean it like that to create an
environment where they feel very safe
and and and able to be themselves I mean
this is the difference between a CG
tiger and a real tiger and the CG tiger
is always going to be my idea of what a
tiger is going to do and that's I'm not
a tiger I am will never and we will
never understand that but when you have
a real exotic animal or any animal
they're so wonderful so themselves so
surprising everything they do is
brilliant so you just have to really
train the crew the humans to to be
comfortable with the idea that we kept
back we we work with the animals natural
behaviors and we observed the
magnificent jessica chastain work with
them there was not a single time in this
movie where anybody is doubling for
Jessica Chastain that is her and her
spooky animal with spree connection with
those animals she loved them so much and
and vice versa as you say this is a
woman's story during wartime
but that transferred to the production
as well it's a book written by a woman a
female screenwriter you your camera
operator is was a woman your stunt
coordinator was a woman almost all the
producers I know Jamie Patricof yes
honoree yeah well basically everyone was
female behind the scenes in that regard
to what do you think that added what was
that important to you is it important to
the people who brought you on how did
that all come about yeah I mean it looks
like it was by design but it wasn't it
was not at all completely organic the I
feel like now in retrospect that this
story has been very carefully cared for
and handed from Antonina who wrote a
diary that was discovered by Diane
Ackerman who wrote a book who passed it
to Angela Whitman to the via these you
know the book was read by one of our
female producers and it's just been
carefully handed from woman to woman all
the way along until we got to shooting
and then you know I I was really
surprised when that picture was taken
for Jessica's article you know that with
all the women in the hollywood reporter
I didn't realize I'd no idea because you
just hire the best person for the job
and though you know frequently those
people are female and yeah it's normal
right yes congratulations Sarah